die die aufhebung der priorisierung dass
das sowas weg doch eine enorme
erwartungshaltung bei den leuten ja das
erweckten erwartungshaltung aber es ist
natürlich auch wichtig weil die
priorisierung in den praxen in den
letzten wochen schon ausgefranst ist an
allen ecken und enden praxis sehr
unterschiedlich strukturiert der eine
hat viele aus der priorisierung gruppe
der andere hat weniger also es ist dann
auch nicht mehr so richtig gerecht in
der praxis so in anderen so aus
notwendigen gründen
und deswegen glaube ich der schritt die
priorisierung für die praxen aufzuheben
richtig gewesen auch wenn das jetzt
natürlich erwartungshaltung geweckt geht
man nicht sofort befriedigend und dem
impfzentrum in hamburg machen sie dass
er weiter mit der privatisierung da
haben wir uns gar nicht auch mit der
behörde da war ich auch sehr dafür dass
wir es erst mal weitermachen weil wenn
man die priorisierung gruppe 3 noch
nicht zu ende hat und jetzt alle anderen
auch sozusagen berechtigt dann fühlen
die sich natürlich benachteiligt weil
sie und das sind der menschen mit dem
kranken die noch keinen termin bekommen
konnten und den können wir jetzt nach
wie vor das angebot im impfzentrum
machen um damit die prio drei noch zu
erfüllen ich glaube das ist ein
vernünftiger mittelweg wie erleben sie
das gerade weil wir dieses bild hier
sehen sie das zum teil auch manchmal
weil das sozusagen auf dem auf dem weg
zur arbeit liegt irrsinnig lange
schlangen
im zentrum hamburg womit hat das zu tun
dass es so schlecht organisiert ist oder
dass leute kommen obwohl sie nicht
angemeldet sind oder dass viel zu viele
auf einmal kommen die vielleicht
impftermine sausen lassen was ist der
hintergrund
das hat schon damit zu tun wie viele
leute überhaupt angemeldet sind das
verlangt sehr weil wir ja immer
hinterher gehen hinter den erste
impfungen wenn wir an einem tag viel
helfen habe ein anderer sechs von später
auch wieder viele erst in neun bis
10.000 kommen ist das schon mal eine
herausforderung allerdings vor allem
dann wenn das wetter gut ist und sich
davon eine ganze menge entscheiden doch
lieber vormittags zu kommen obwohl der
termin am nachmittag ist und das führt
dann zu staus es liegt tatsächlich ist
tatsächlich mal überprüft
36 prozent unserer impflinge kommen über
zwei stunden zu früh
und dann haben sie vormittags natürlich
ein stoff mit welcher begründung denn
weil das wetter gut wir haben nochmal
gefragt
ich habe noch was vor über noch zur oma
zum kaffeetrinken
wir machen noch ein ausflug also sieht
wie viele ideen den die menschen haben
und denken dagegen immer früher hin
mit dem erfolg dass wir nach zwei
stunden war die schlange stehen also
macht nicht so richtig sind oder kommen
auch gar nicht weil das wetter besonders
schön ist und man vielleicht mal an die
see fahren könnte das hatten wir auch
schon aber das hat glaube ich wieder
nachgelassen also das weil das wetter so
schlecht darstellen wenn dich fest wir
stellen schon fest dass montags wenn
menschen montags einen termin haben dass
sie die bei samstag oder sonntag schon
mal kommen weil das ja schwierig ist mit
der arbeit also da wird der termin
selbständig vorverlegt und solche dinge
führen wenn sie ein ebenso wie das
hamburger dann bei 10.000 empfingen am
tag wirklich am limit fahren ja dann
machen auch 300 menschen die das tun
einen riesenunterschied und führen dann
zu staus die dann manchmal bis in die
chancen gegen eigentlich sind sie ja
super organisiert euch zumindest in
mathe haben ja bis zu 11.000 leute an
einem tag geschafft ja das können wir
aber wie gesagt dann ist voraussetzung
dass dann alle pünktlich gekommen so und
wenn die leute jetzt zwei stunden eher
kommen oder oder wochenende oder so oder
zwei tage er kommt im film sie dann
trotzdem oder sagen sie ab nach hause
nein die werden dann schon geimpft sagen
sie es bitte nicht sagen
die werden natürlich jetzt aber sie wird
warten die folge ist ein tag hat dann
ist man gleich zwei drei stunden da
draußen stand zusteht und wenn ja wenn
es regnet dann wird weiters gibt es auch
leute die die zweite impfung erst gar
nicht mehr so zusagen machen weil sie
beschlossen haben in urlaub zu fahren
kurzfristig also es gibt schon termin
versäume wir wissen natürlich nicht
warum die nicht kommen aber das sind
tatsächlich wenige muss man sagen also
die die impf moral die zweite impfung
auch in anspruch zu nehmen ist sehr sehr
hoch und das ist sehr erfreulich weil
wir wollen ja dass alle vollständig
geleert und klar im stoff ganz
grundsätzlich sechs millionen sind jetzt
für die nächsten tage wochen angekündigt
was heißt das für sie das heißt für das
impfzentrum dass wir tatsächlich wieder
ausreichend impfstoff bekommen das heißt
wir können tatsächlich in der woche in
hamburg 55.000 menschen impfen damit sie
mir dann auch gut ausgelastet wenn die
dann tatsächlich die impfdosen
tatsächlich alle kommen und pünktlich
kommen würde das auch für die praxen
bedeuten mit dreieinhalb millionen
impfdosen das dann auch dort wieder viel
mehr ankommt da hatten wir tatsächlich
in den letzten wochen häufiger diesem
fall dass man bis
welt aber nicht die menge an impfdosen
bekommt die man bestellt hat für die
erstimpfung und das ist für die praxen
ein riesenaufwand menschen die einen
termin haben dann kurzfristig zu
verlegen
das heißt sie bestellen eine bestimmte
menge die es ihnen zugesagt und kriegen
dann aber weniger geliefert
weil die gesamtmenge wohl zu hoch ist
und dann wird quotiert und dann kriegen
sie eben stadt oder sagen wir zehn
bestellten flächen kriegen sie nur acht
ja wir müssen sie zwölf leuten absagen
und die auf einen anderen termin
verlegen verstehe
und weil wir in den letzten wochen
soviel darüber gesprochen haben über
dieses berühmte wörtchen zusätzlich wo
ich sie heute schon mal hier haben
kriegen sie jetzt von jens spart
zusätzlich impfstoff für zwölfjährige
gut dass wir das mal geklärt haben für
zwölf jahren nicht den eindruck wurde ja
ständig erwecken dass sein dass für
kinder für kinder ab 12 zusätzlich
impfstoff bereit gestellt werden würde
davon habe ich noch nichts gehört dass
wir hinter tatsächlich bekommen würden
es sieht aber auch so aus dass die stiko
eine empfehlung geben wird die die
anzahl der kinder die in diese kategorie
priorisiert fallen ja sehr gering sein
wird weil nur kinder mit schweren
vorerkrankungen in den haag in die im
priorisierung einfallen werden
aber auch da wie fanden sie dass die
diese diese formulierung von seiten der
politik zusätzlich wir werden zusätzlich
der eindruck wurde erweckt es gebe
plötzlich die wundersame impfstoff
vermehrung wenn die gibt es ja offen
sind ich habe mich gefreut dass für mich
zusätzlich immer gut mit mir ja immer
gut
wann haben sie verstanden dass das ein
anderes zusätzliches als das zusätzlich
dass sie kennen es ist ja nicht nur da
so ist es auch bei den impfdosen die für
die betriebsärzte vorgesehen ist die
werden dann bei den praxen abgezogen
also die gesamtmenge hat sich nicht
verändert nach meinem kenntnisstand also
wird noch anders verteilt
aber das ist ja nicht das was wir wollen
wir wollen natürlich mehr impfstoff
haben aber ich verstehe dass er nicht da
ist
es macht dann wenig sind noch mehr
verteilstellen aufzubauen weil dann
installiert ein bisschen weniger
eingängig wo da die logik drin liegt
irgendwie geht in ihrer erklärung dafür
warum wird das so gemacht
ich kann da nur mal sagen mit blick auf
die politiker die hier sitzen
und auch aus der regierungsfraktion sind
es eine politische entscheidung denke
ich dass man die betriebsärzte mit
hinein genommen hat was ja grundsätzlich
erfreulich ist werden wir so viel
impfstoff haben dass wir viele brauchen
ja um weil wir nicht alleine mehr
klarkommen klar dann ist mir jeder hand
die impfung kann natürlich willkommen
so habe keine frage aber wenn ich nicht
so viel impfstoff habe und schon die
praxen teilweise die impfdosen nicht
bekommen diese bestellt haben und wir
auch nicht im impfzentrum dann macht das
nicht so wahnsinnig viel sinn jetzt noch
mehr im stelle aufzubauen
für den tag wurf ganz ganz viel
schokolade absolut einverstanden
vorstadt zimmermann warum wird das so
gemacht können sie über das mal erklären
ja das ist auch für pr natürlich dr
das ist eine form von pr zu sagen es
kommt mehr die leute haben ja hoffnung
es ist ja ganz interessante situation
weil als das thema impfung aufgaben was
ja prinzipiell unglaublich toll ist das
so schnell ein thema wo er und ihre
möglichkeit war ja durchaus eine gewisse
skepsis am anfang jetzt versteht jeder
wie wichtig das ist und da wird eben
immer werden immer versprechen gemacht
und nach außen signalisiert macht euch
locker es geht voran
denn die impfzentren sind das eine ich
kenne das aus meiner heimatstadt
düsseldorf wo das sehr rund läuft aber
das reicht natürlich nicht und die
niedergelassenen ärzte beziehungsweise
die ärzte die sich um die betriebsärzte
die mit einzuziehen macht natürlich sinn
so wie man früher das wissen sie nicht
alle waren sie noch zu jung rein im
linken haben zwar die gleiche getränk
jahres war der werbeblock einer
bereinigung und macht dort in die
schulen gehen
von wegen zwölfjährige macht ja sehen
dorthin zu gehen wo die menschen sind
nicht die menschen zu holen wo sie in
der regel nicht sind oder nicht so
häufig und der impfstoff reicht eben
nicht und da hat die regierung an der
stelle eben auch versagt das zu
organisieren und insofern wird jetzt
immer wieder man redet ja schon
einsparen 2 sparen 3 sparen wird eben
immer versprochen sparen ist die neue
zeit an das ist die 90 kann bisher nur
scheuer ein scheuer ist sozusagen einmal
500 millionen der steuer sind eine
milliarde
es sind ganz viele millionen von
impfungen und das läuft eben nicht so
rund und das ist spaß beiseite natürlich
schon ernsthaft weil die bereitschaft
ist da das ist die gute nachricht weil
ich die erwartungshaltung wo die
erwartungshaltung ist da und der dass
die menschen früher kommt verstehe ich
weil da ist ja auch eine gewisse
freudige erwartung also da ist gute
laune im zentrum für die die impfen
dürfen und ihnen wissen jetzt geht's los
aber es ist eben nach wie vor auch nach
einem jahr hat diese regierung ist nicht
vermocht genug impfstoff zu organisieren
und das ist schon bemerkenswert
schrecklich erklären weil sie sind teil
dieser regierung sind sie noch als spd
ja alles klagen dieser tage macht man
weiß das nicht so genau bei der spd ob
sie noch bei dem trubel neuerrichtung
cdu gerne teil dieser regierung aber wir
kritisieren auch wenn was schief
also dann sicherlich jetzt wir reden
vielleicht war genau aber ist das pr wie
frau strack zimmermann sagt pr an andere
erich für veräppeln
oder was ist das dann also erst mal ist
glaube ich gut wenn man und das ist in
der tat so dass wir uns glaube ich alle
gefreut haben dass der impfstoff da ist
und dass er auch zum teil in deutschland
entwickelt wurde und dass die hausärzte
ich erlebt dass bei mir im wahlkreis
ziehen kann man sehr dankbar sein wie
gut das organisiert wurde auch in den
impfzentren bei mir mit der bundeswehr
zusammen aber natürlich das problem
bleibt die warten alle auf ausreichend
impfstoff das ist defizite stars und das
sind die leute die leute verstehen das
doch die leute verstehen doch ja aber
das ist ja gerade also ja ich finde
sozusagen das problem was wir jetzt an
vielen stellen gesehen haben und da
stimme ich ihnen zu ist ja dass häufig
so gerät wurde da kommt mehr und ich
habe diese debatte um das zusätzlich sie
haben das jetzt gerade so ein bisschen
naja karikiert aber es war eine sehr
ernsthafte debatte auch unter den
ministerpräsidenten
weil die alle gedacht haben nach der
runde der gesundheitsminister mit ihren
sparen es gibt mehr impfstoff es gibt
nach oben drauf und dann hat man in der
runde bei der bundeskanzlerin gemerkt
der hier entspannen meint das ganz
anders also das ist keine zusätzliche
menge die da kommt und und das ist ein
riesenproblem weil dann natürlich
erwartungen geweckt werden weil da
schlagzeilen entstehen weil dann die
eltern lesen jetzt sind wir dran weil
jetzt die impfzentren denken sie kriegen
was oben drauf und und das sind
enttäuschungen die hätte man sich
ersparen können
wenn man vernünftig kommuniziert hat und
das ist etwas wo ich dann natürlich als
sozialdemokrat der mit in der regierung
ist wo ich automatisch mit in der
verantwortung bin wo ich die e mails
kriege die anrufe aus meinem wahlkreis
von den ärzten aus dem zentrum wo ich
mich dann rechtfertigen muss aber
zugeben muss man hat er natürlich wenig
handlungsmöglichkeiten wenn man sich
darauf verlassen hat dass der
gesundheitsminister im kreise mit seinen
länder-kollegen da schon vernünftig klar
rede das heißt das hat sie auch
überrascht dieses wörtchen zusätzlich
ich habe mich auch gefreut weil ich
dachte okay jetzt hat irgendwo noch eine
möglichkeit gefunden zusätzlichen
impfstoff zu kriegen sondern auf einmal
löst sich das in luft auf und dann habe
ich gemerkt das ist eine weitere
enttäuschung und jetzt muss man sagen da
waren ja leider einige enttäuschungen in
den letzten wochen durch das
gesundheitsministerium und das trägt zu
einem frust bei also anstatt dass man
sich darauf konzentriert wie kriegen wir
mehr impfstoff dann kriegen wir das
bläser haben ist es die enttäuschung
beim impfchaos dann haben wir beim
testen das erlebt an mehreren stellen
jetzt vor kurzem wieder diese ganzen
testzentren die irgendwo wachsen uns
nicht abgerechnet werden und das ist
frustrierend weil man einen teil der
verantwortung haben sie zu recht gesagt
wenn man kann aber wenig dagegen machen
und da sollten wenn alle minister
verlässlich arbeiten würden an der
stelle
hätten wir das problem weniger freudig
politische kommunikation
was ist ist das sozusagen an der grenze
zum seriösen was man da teilweise macht
so ziemlich das einzige beispiel hat den
ball recht bin auch gespannt was herr
heinrich gleich uns vorrechnet diese
prognose auch aus dem
gesundheitsministerium die entspannen
der mann sagte ende juli 90 prozent mit
erstimpfung dann ging es runter auf 80%
erstimpfung ende juli und ich bin
gespannt wie sie das gleich einschätzen
also warum geht man immer mit solchen
überbordenden zahlen nach vorne und
weckt eine erwartungshaltung gibt von
dem man von vornherein weiß das kannst
du nicht einlösen
ich kann ihnen dafür keinerlei antwort
aber die schnelle schlagzeile ja weil
sie sich jetzt um die schnelle
schlagzeile und es geht auch um den
wohnungs beispielsweise in einer woche
hineinzugehen mit einer guten nachricht
und die hoffnung mit dieser guten
nachricht jetzt irgendwie die
berichterstattung zu dominieren
nur ich verstehe es auch nicht ganz weil
man wird ja schnell von der realität
wieder eingeholt und dann ist die das
schlechte image nur umso größer deswegen
verkehr ist mir eher mit überforderung
als mit bösen willen ist dass herr nicht
so schwer zu berechnen also ich muss mir
das nicht anders zu tun aber wovon gehen
sie beispielsweise aus sie haben einen
relativ guten überblick ende juli
wieviele wie viel prozent dieses landes
werden da die erstimpfung haben also
ende juli könnten wir es auf 70 prozent
schaffen
aber das ist deshalb nur schwer zu
berechnen weil diese wellen zwischen
erster und zweiter also wie viel
impfstoff habe ich und wann kommen die
zweite impfung rein das eine land macht
die zweite impfung nach drei wochen die
ist andere land nach sechs wochen bei
bayern stecken zum beispiel haben sie
einfach diese schwankungen drin und das
macht berechnung extrem schwierig weil
sie müssen ja dann wenn sie im stoff
eine fixe menge haben müssen sie ja
genau wissen ich habe dann soviel zweite
impfung zu machen und den rest mit dann
für ersten punkt geholt
das sehen sie zwar schon jetzt auch an
den zahlen die zahlen für die erste
impfung gehen ja nicht so schnell hoch
wie die für die zweite impfung weil wir
jetzt in der phase sind wo wir sehr
viele zweite impfung machen also haben
sie da den höheren anstieg als bei der
zahl der der erstimpfung aber die anzahl
der insgesamt getätigten impfung bleibt
dabei trotzdem dann gleich karl josef
laumann und wahrscheinlich bestens
bekannt was aus nrw knorriger
ostwestfale hat in der vergangenen woche
hier aus seinem herzen keine mördergrube
gemacht und hat mal erzählt was für ihn
als zuständigen minister in nrw was das
bedeutet das handling und das management
diese impfkampagne hör mal kurz rein
also dass wir die in phrasierung jetzt
auf geräte mit selbst ich weil die prio
drei so groß ist ich muss es ja umsätzen
ein land die ist gar nicht beherrschbar
muss man ganz klar zu sagen da sind sind
ganz viele berufsgruppen rein
geschrieben worden mit mit millionen von
leuten dann ist ja noch rein geschrieben
worden wer so arbeitet oder so wohl dass
er ein höheres ansteckungsrisiko wird
auch zu prio 3 da bin ich bei drei
viertel der nordrhein westfälischen
bevölkerung ja ganz also brauche ich
nicht ärgert sie bringt mir nur
sie bringt mir nur er da sagen dann auf
einmal was weiß ich die leute die bei
finanzämtern arbeiten warum werde ich
gegen eine willige feuerwehr war ob ich
die müllabfuhr wichtiger wie die die
kraftwerke das ist nicht zu handeln und
wenn man dann so ein winter hat dann ist
mir lieber wir haben gar keine mehr aber
jetzt die frage dass wir zum beispiel
die justiz in nordrhein westfalen die
imker haben weil wir es so wollten
aber zum beispiel rechtsanwälte nicht
ist doch vollkommen klar dass die
anwältin wir schreiben ja wieso wird der
staatsanwalt und ich als die bei der die
angeklagten vertritt während ich gehe
ins priorisiert soll ich ja es ist so
was soll ich dazu antworten was soll er
da zu antworten
geraten sie an solche grenzen heran
rückt näher das ist in der tat natürlich
die aufgabe von einer laumann oder hier
auch von unserer gesundheitssenatorin
die behörden prüfen die berechtigung da
kann ich mich fein raus halten wir
prüfen teamfähigkeit als ärzte aber in
der tat ist das schwierig wenn die wenn
die gruppe sehr groß ist aber es ist
natürlich bei der brio drei auch eine
gruppe dabei von menschen noch mit
vorerkrankungen die tatsächlich ein
höheres gesundheitliches risiko haben
und da muss jetzt als arzt sagen es ist
richtig wenn wir die nach wie vor
priorisieren
die frage ist nur musste man die anderen
gruppen alle noch in dieser gruppe bei
nehmen das ist eine frage die ist bei
politisch entschieden worden
und jetzt muss man mit der entscheidung
getroffen hat halt auch erleben als wir
das prüfen muss das lustige ist ja ich
meine herr laumann umgehen sparen sind
in einer partei da würde ich doch mal
den hörer in die hand nehmen und sagen
herr jens jetzt gibt man gummi hier
kommt man in die gänge und macht das
heißt es wird dann auch über die medien
erzählt was nicht klappt und das kann
ich nicht verstehen und ich habe ihn ja
lange erwachsen ja mit am kabinettstisch
ist denn da montag nur uns nicht wird er
mit auf den tisch hauen gesagt leute so
geht's nicht
es warten fünf priorisierung wird er in
den bundesländern auch noch einmal
einzeln festgelegt also es gibt hier
unterschiedliche gruppen ländern aber
nein das licht beim gesundheitsminister
und ich glaube das ist aber auch dieser
kurze ausschnitt der die schwierigkeit
gezeigt hat weil ich doch selbst als
jemand der nicht als person mit am
kabinettstisch sitzt doch mitgekriegt
habe wer sich alles gemeldet hat als
priorisierung geredet wurde gesagt hat
warum nicht wir auch
und da sind teilweise sehr berechtigte
fragen bei muss man ja auch sagen so und
das zu entscheiden als
landesgesundheitsministerin
landesgesundheitsminister wie macht man
das ist eine verdammt hohe verantwortung
also ich glaube das ist nicht ganz
einfach das einfach so weg zu wischen
und zu sagen
dann sollen sie doch mal miteinander
telefonieren da trägt man verdammt hohe
verantwortung und die große gefahr die
ich sehe wenn die realisierung
aufgehoben wird ist dass die hinten
runter fallen die nicht den guten draht
haben und die nicht so zu sagen
vielleicht auch die energie haben jetzt
permanent hinterher zu telefonieren und
anzurufen irgendwo und hinterher zu sein
und deswegen glaube ich muss man sich
immer ich verstehe dass man jetzt die
infusion aufhebt und nochmal ich glaube
dass hausärzte gerade sehr gut
einschätzen können wen sie wählen sie
impfen und wie sie das machen aber wir
als politik sind verantwortlich zu
gucken was machen wir mit denen die
drohnen hinten runterzufallen wie ist
das mit mobilem teams wo geht man in die
sozialen brennpunkte auch noch mal rein
also wie ist man da das ist eine aufgabe
die wir haben wo ich glaubt in hamburg
wird das glaube ich auch gemacht und
nordrhein-westfalen bei mir
niedersachsen
das ist eine große verantwortung die
politik hat aber es ist echten es ist
wirklich eine herkulesaufgabe mit dieser
priorisierung der leistungen werde zwar
ehrlich sein
die impfverordnung ist aber schon ein
paar monate alt also die die jetzt sagen
die gruppe ist mir zu groß das wussten
die vor drei monaten hatte gold rush
mark oder mitgekriegt was allen jetzt
merken sie müssen es umsetzen und in der
umsetzung stellen sie fest das war
vielleicht nicht ganz optimal was wir da
alle gemeinsam beschlossen haben also
die impfverordnung ist schon ein paar
monate alt und jetzt ist man schlauer
das ist eben so wir sind in einer
pandemie
wir machen viele dinge zum ersten mal
und natürlich lernen wir lernen jeden
tag dazu und dann muss man eben auch mal
sagen das war letzten endes die gruppe
ist zu groß jetzt müssen wir es beenden
haben sie eigentlich mittlerweile
heinrich erkenntnisse wann wird der der
nächste schuss dann fällig also wie
lange sind wir dann irgendwann endlich
mal diese impfung haben es ist eine der
schein ja wir wissen es nicht nein wir
wissen s wirklich noch nicht haben sie
eine vermutung der idee ich will
eigentlich nicht spekulieren ich bin
dafür auch nicht der super experte das
müssten sie die virologen dann fragen
die das dann noch ein dämmstoff
entwickler machen
ich gehe persönlich davon aus dass wir
eine zweite dass wir eine weitere oder
auffrischungsimpfungen brauchen werden
aber noch von gefühl ich meine die nagel
sie nicht darauf fest aber wird das
etwas sein was in mehreren jahren
stattfindet oder nach ein paar monat
oder jedes jahr und ich also ich
persönlich denke er das wird eine
jährliche impfung seien
das hätte auch einen großen vorteil man
könnte sie mit der influenza impfung
kombinieren und dann ist es auch wieder
nur eine spritze am ende des tages also
okay dass das könnte ja das könnte
gelingen
simultan impfungen sind ja nicht selten
ist das stimmt ja wenn er sich im sommer
machen da können sich auch mal
synchronisieren lassen und dann kriegen
sie mal sechs impfungen an
das ist nicht das große problem super
und weil sie von gerade sagten wir tun
dazu furchtbar überrascht dass diese
prior diese gruppe 3 dass die so riesig
großes ähnlich überrascht sind wir auch
von der tatsache dass wir plötzlich
einen digitalen impfausweis brauchen
das hat uns ja auch relativ kalt
erwischt ja wir haben alle gedacht der
gelbe riese aber erreicht ja also der
der digitale ist ja eine zusätzliche
maßnahme gut der gelbe ist nicht
fälschungssicher nicht wirklich das kann
man rein na ja herr land wie kommen sie
dann an den digitalen ausweis
das ist die frage also und bereiten sie
sowas vor gibt es sowas immer so ist das
klar wir haben ja die daten unserer
impflinge ja wir werden über diese daten
das mit mit auf digitalem wege auch den
impfungen zur verfügung stellen können
das würde ich als fälschungssicher
bezeichnen aber wenn sie irgendeine
andere stelle haben die dann was macht
ihr denn dann überträgt vom gelben
ausweis in digital wo ist jetzt die
fälschungssicherheit
es muss doch möglich sein irgendwie auf
europäischer ebene etwas zu finden wo
man sagt es auch hier ist mein mobiles
endgerät und bitte schön hier ist mein
nachweis dass ich zweimal gegen kobe 19
aber das können sie in ein kleid oder
was irgendwie deutschland center und da
haben sie diese daten und der praxis
habe ich natürlich auch ich habe eine
patientin oder impfling selber geimpft
dann habe ich in meinem praxis
verwaltungssystem die daten drin
ausdehnen kann ich diesen code
generieren und dann ist das auch
fälschungssicher aber wenn sie aus dem
gelben ausweis übertragen irgendwo im
gesundheitsamt oder wohl es dann gemacht
werden muss dann ist das ja nicht
schnell und sicher oder was muss gemacht
werden
denn wenn sie heute einen stempel bei
amazon bestellen dann steht darunter
andere bestellten zusätzlich
also offensichtlich ist das schon eine
methode ich gebe jetzt ihre daten neben
ihren stempel ist detektiv an dem punkt
kommt dann und dann mache ich natürlich
keine ahnung wer denkt da steht jetzt
bei antec steht was anderes muss also in
dem moment entscheiden ist derjenige
diejenige ein zweimal geimpft oder nicht
das ist natürlich so was von antiquiert
und das kommt davon wenn ein land nicht
digitalisiert ist oder das ist in den
letzten vier jahren komplett versagt
worden und jetzt fällt uns das auch an
der stelle der band no fear jahr wurde
das ist 12 ich wollte gnädig sein aber
was soll ich also aber das ist ja ein
weites feld jetzt digitalisierung im
gesundheitswesen aufzumachen
beim datenschutz an also die zwar nicht
das kommt ja also elektronische
patientenakte jetzt ist der
datenschützer wieder dran und sagt nie
doch nicht so also mit dem handy umgeht
was wir für spuren hinterlassen im netz
durch das ist ja nicht das thema aber
das heißt doch die fdp schon lange dass
wir spuren im netz hinterlassen er aber
das ist doch die frage wie menschen sie
müssten doch den menschen sagen so wenn
ihr diese daten freigibt also aktiv
sagen ja wir geben die daten frei das
ist ja der punkt es geht darum an werken
schutz das nicht daten sozusagen
ungefragt abgefischt werden
aber ich würde jetzt mal wetten dass die
möglichkeit in einer elektronischen
ausweis hat also wo das dann mal ist
hinterlegt ist jeder froh ist wenn das
als solches hinterlegt ist und die frage
ist dass man aktiv an kreuz
jawohl das will ich es geht nur darum
dass nicht sozusagen abgefischt wird
ohne dass sie es überhaupt mitbekommen
dass abgefischt wird in den momenten
müssen sie auf daten zugreifen das sind
persönliche daten
und aber anders werden sie daran werde
mich daran vorbeikommen ich aber der
digitale impfnachweis für coop 19 wird
ja kommen
also ich glaube ende juni soll er fertig
sein jetzt kann man darüber diskutieren
ob das zu spät ist oder nicht der
digitale impfausweis also der der alle
impfung umfasst soll anfang nächsten
jahres fertig sein also das wird ja da
sein
das geht ja anscheinend mit datenschutz
minuten noch sicher so eine lösung wird
datenschutz sicher sei aber dass das an
der zeit ist das jetzt mal zu
digitalisieren
da sofort dabei jetzt kann man immer
wieder kritisieren dauert zu lange und
so weiter und so fort aber ich glaube
das ist jetzt schon okay dass es ende
des monats in digitalen impfnachweis
gibt und ich glaube der anreizen haben
sie recht dass man nicht mit diesen
gelben impfpass sieht bei mir auch schon
ziemlich zäh dass man damit nicht
darunter steht sondern wieder seinen
neuen digitalen dokument vor weiß es ist
doch glaube ich jetzt auch gebaut und
dann macht man das